a couple things during the quarantine
try getting an internet look up yeah and
then try reporting stolen car now you
know daddy has well his hobby that is
awesome yeah but it's still it's a Prius
but you did it was your car yeah and so
forget you had it my buddy my buddy
driving he happened to have left the
keys in it
hey but he's a [ __ ] well he probably
was like what are the chances we all do
this I've never done that in my entire
37 years on this planet left keys in the
car well he's overnight no no it was he
went in to see his buddy he was gonna be
his buddy was working out go talk to his
buddies gonna come back out yeah just
like whatever I've never done it well
anyway somebody probably rode by on
their bike and went let me get in that
talk to my buddies a cop who said we run
plates all day usually they find it if
you report it right away I didn't really
report a ride oh you're a little lit and
that's that's Brian and that lady a
little boy was being reported by my
friend and my friend your friends into
it cop said you're not the registered
owner you can't make a police report
cuz he's borrowing yes so now I gotta go
through it and what I realized is I I
went to the police department and they
go I'm gonna walk in and they laugh at
you they go for reporter pretty nope
they go uh nope they go can't come in
here nobody in here cuz of kovin I'm
like ah so you gotta call it in problem
is when you call it it's got to be in
the right districts and I gotta find the
right district where it is and where was
all the car but you got yeah then they
sent me a dispatch guy the dispatch guy
goes I never report patrol car come out
we're not gonna do that it took a long
time they were very cool they were very
cool it for example and you know what
but during the quip during kovat it's
tough COBIT or not I'm just glad they
actually acted like they were gonna
search down this prius cuz you know they
don't give a mind don't be mean no but
they run plates they might they might
find out though they're looking for real
they got real so [ __ ] this LA's finest
they assured me you know it was cool
about every one of them they go we're
really sorry you're having a bad day
we're sorry this happened to you I was
like that's nice you guys very nice
don't get back out there
I appreciate that and I said stop
everything
hold everything and find this Prius
his Prius it's me tuft of Prius that's a
tough karna I don't like your attitude
that's a pretty just chalk it up as a
loss just right well it's already you
don't care could you lend it to your
friend I mean so it's like you don't
care for the car you know they're gay
it's a plug-in ass white yeah and you
don't drive this plug-in but you don't
drive it before selling yes like
bicycles will pass you up yeah I'll get
on the e by King David off called it he
goes a Prius a Prius otherwise known as
you can punch me in the face and I'll
never do anything right yeah
I won't I won't hit you back no matter
what you do to baby yeah but the cops
are second all right yeah we're on it I
liked having a red Prius you remember I
read a very gay very capers of maroon it
was Barcelona read please get it right
Barcelona birthday and it was adorable
it was it a little sexier than
dishwasher with wheels and what's cool
about that is that nobody [ __ ] with you
like E guys in cars cops everybody kind
of like and well I got pulled over
let's go I got that's it I got pulled
over by a cop and I and he said you know
fast you're gone I go officer I can
explain here's what he goes didn't have
it in eco I had it in supercharged
because you see that the button here he
laughs he started laughing he let me off
I'm a [ __ ] I'm remember I had a Prius
when I was driving though I'm sure did
it was like my third car at a Prius just
to use it for camp stuff I would eat I
have [ __ ] name of food
I'd have salsa hot sauce on my head I'd
wipe it in the seats you don't hate it
that [ __ ] car I would walk out car
I'd check it then get in it I hated that
I don't know it was like a go-kart he
just didn't like it you have such a
problem with it look at you back in the
day yes that looks so wrong something
about you and a Prius right that's
amazing yeah I trade that bad boy I gave
it back
you look different I mean yes it's very
it's a nice car though all right I hated
it I mean it's just either great car I
hate the best cars in some ways and
that's not true of anything in some ways
there are they
I hated it they did it yeah uni is so
slow you got problems you need power
it's so slow I mean you're ridiculous
though you're the other end of the
extreme yeah you drive a rs200 arse -
what is it called
just just say you drive a Porsche though
I know what does it call what is gt2 all
right a GT - RS sorry dude give a [ __ ]
it's your primary car I do respect that
I respect cuz my uncle had sports cars
and never drove them and cover them honk
you got them in a coke with a car cover
ya know and will drive them literally
once a month if for like a couple hours
on a Sunday I'm like I'll get a point
you drive the [ __ ] out of that it's your
only car I don't anybody does that I
don't know anyone who does it yeah I
Drive the piss out of it though yeah I
Drive the piss out thing now his dad now
is daddy gonna tuned in two weeks to get
to 900 horsepower yeah he is because a
gentleman reached out who knows what
he's doing
your son - so I went why not problem huh
I just want a 900 horsepower 900 a this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]